- [Narrator] Midterm
elections are coming up.
But does your vote
actually make a difference?
U.S. voter turnout is amongst the lowest
in the entire developed world.
And it might be because we feel like
our individual vote
won't make a difference
in the mass of votes.
Like one Skittle will make a difference
in a jar of hundreds.
But it's time we stop horsing
around and we get to voting.
'Cause democracy, it's
like pretty important.
You might think one vote
won't make a difference.
But if you and the person next to you
feel the same way, then
that creates a domino effect
that could lead to the
loss of a bunch of votes.
Plus who says a few votes
can't make a difference?
Check this out.
In 2000, George W. Bush won
Florida by only 537 votes.
About six million votes
were cast in Florida,
which means that he won by only 0.009%
and this gave him the presidency.
In 1839, Marcus Morton became
the governor of Massachusetts
thanks to one vote.
So like, out of this pool of ducks,
this one dude made history.
I know it feels like our
votes are microscopic,
but so is that bacteria
that caused the Black Plague
and that killed about
25 million people, so
small things can have a big impact.
In 1994, two candidates
from Wyoming State House
received the exact same number of votes.
Randall Luthi won the seat
when his name, written
on a ping pong ball,
was drawn from a cowboy hat.
And again in 2011, Tanya Flanagan
and Linda Meisenheimer tied
during a primary election
in North Las Vegas.
Meisenheimer drew the higher card
securing her spot in the general election,
which she went on to lose
but that's not the point.
Another example comes from 2008,
when Democrat Al Franken
beat Republican Norm Coleman
by 312 votes out of almost
2.9 million votes cast.
312 votes is about 0.011%.
That's like nothing.
And there's so many
other examples for this.
This happens a lot ya'll.
Especially during midterms.
Like push your friends
to the voting polls,
bring your aunt and uncle,
your brother, Adam and
his boyfriend, Steve.
So regardless of what
party you are voting for,
you should get to voting.
(fun music)